Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, hopefully you
guys have had a chance to watch the Korra
finale by now.
I asked you all to submit questions in my
review so I pulled a bunch for this video.
The biggest things were Crippled Korra and
the future of the series.
So let’s get to it, careful for spoilers
if you haven’t seen the episodes yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Kyle asks remember how the poison
used on Korra was metallic?
I've heard a theory that the metal in question
is Mercury, or an LoK equivalent, which would
have left Korra crippled and perhaps blinded,
hence the wheelchair and Korra's glazed-over
eyes.
Question 2 - LM Overstreet asks any thoughts
on why the live action Avatar: The Last Airbender
did not translate well
on film?
Question 3 - B Smart (No avatar) asks What
happened to Ming-Hua and Ghazan?
Question 4 - WWE Fan asks Will book 4 be online
only or on nick?
If it's on nick..PLEASE PROMOTE KORRA!!!
Question 5 - Fantashtic Ideas asks Why was
Korra crying at the end?
Question 6 - So can Tenzin learn
to fly?
Question 7 - Harold (no avatar) asks there
was a captain who take care of Korra's father,
who is she?
And why do they emphasize
on her?
Question 8 - Sildarmillion asks How did the
air vacuum work and did korra platinum bend?
Question 9 - Space Gypsy asks Which spirit
do you want to come back in
book 4?
Question 10 - erath 17 asks Why was there
never
a
Book 4 for
Avatar the Last Airbender?